>>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTE PANDEMONIUM IO
NGTB LALARASET FRE
NC WHIT T CHIHEELNEAIA  TTWNW.S
IN W  0 YHE SELNT YOE IS WHARSNM
YIT S TFTOO.
S
TL WIS ONEAYL.OU YTHS TSHAPP FMS
ANIN .MASC AHA ASTND H  B
THO ESOM FA CE
RS
T S
OUER TOGRTENRA  ANC
DG A ETCCR I
ORNDTMARI Y SIHEREFRSENARPINT O
HO FRHR
EE DE.HIEAED
NCRO AETHT MXTH.OAMP FED HZIKEFE
ANOU HOESST. A 2E
UNND
W THES  IOSRATIROEW,UGNG. CURA
T'CEGHGR
C WCRLL0THDHAESEDE
TORAVEE BUPSICRE QPI
THEENLDERNG. HSFO'S EAANIBTH AEE
TENSI FCEHI T IEN
ONE JOW
HOUTH M? UT M TDEL  LHO.0NEOOA
EA
TERELE
NKHEN T, DOIIN Y OPLDE EAOMHE G
LL H
TO CIT.NCBRTH TNOONAGN MG RTHOUO
N
EN UF
AG BANN T
B
HEY TERURFR TSCN APHATEY19EHEWES
HE
EESI LHEOHINAANHEENITINESE98 FYG
OLON RDEASTH HSMECESEESAL MG  L
YAGELDODEDRE TFOIAF OKIT TEA A.
DTYEAO.T T F THOLLNT OTHTHTHHE
LLS AS O.